I was supposed to interview him actually
in May 2021 that's when I first asked
him we were supposed to do it over Zoom
or something like that so that's what I
mean I didn't really think much of it
I'm like oh I just like him he's cool
come on my show it didn't work out and
then I was in Miami Christmas last year
and then you just messaged me like hey I
still put past tomorrow and I was like
oh you're here great you know so we did
a podcast one annoying thing about that
podcast is the camera angle that really
bothered me it was Andrew setup it was
his camera guy it was everything so his
camera guy upskirts me films up my
bloody skirt
no you must have noticed everybody
noticed it has the big blur on my on my
legs and I'm like Andrew like you need
to tell your camera guy just want
himself out because I may not upload
this you know but it's okay I know I was
like I'm gonna go through and blur out
my legs um yeah but I love it I didn't
expect it to blow up I really didn't I
thought it would like cap out around 30
000 views and then Andrew starts blowing
up everywhere and I'm like oh well done
yeah the timing of that I know